seven eight three zero four seven five
zero I never know who's going to call I
never know what the questions will be or
anything
Jason do we have our next caller here
I'm sitting here waiting oh here it is
all right six one seven eight three zero
four seven five zero let's start with
your name and where you're calling from
welcome to the David Pakman show
hi my name is Jose I'm from near Chicago
Illinois
great what uh what's on your mind Zack I
was just wondering what are your
thoughts on people who claim to have
like spiritual insight into the meaning
of life in the universe while under the
influence of like psychedelics uh like
DMT or LSD or mushrooms and things like
that yeah okay so it's sort of like a
two-part question I guess number one is
my views on the concept of everything
from spiritual and supernatural insights
psychic powers ESP etc right because I
think before you you discuss whether you
believe drugs could be a conduit to that
type of insight you need to figure out
whether you you sort of believe in that
type of insight I tend to be very very
science and evidence based on that issue
so I don't believe that psychics exist
in the sense that I've never actually
seen or or seen any evidence of or
experienced or or heard of anybody very
convincingly explain a so-called psychic
experience of real spiritual insight
mediums that communicate with the dead
being able to tell the future etc etc I
believe that these are skills that can
be learned many people call it cold
reading period so generally I'm sort of
skeptical of the concept of so-called
supernatural insights or whatever now in
terms of drugs triggering what two
people is legitimately a spiritual or
life-changing experience I have no
problem with that whatsoever I mean we
know that there are hallucinogenics and
other drugs which very significantly
impact the way that the brain functions
and I have no problem whatsoever with
someone feeling like they've had a very
positive or enlightening experience from
that
you're nodding to me Jason I don't know
if you agree with that general view well
I actually have say had a few
experiences myself and one of them was
actually around ayahuasca DMT if you
will and everyone has the same kind of
sees the same things has the same
experience where they are lifted out of
this planet and they go to other places
they kind of see similar things so and I
think was a positive trauma for me as
well giving I was you know in a certain
safe space if you will so I I think
there is something to that
but how quantifiable and scientifically
proven that is but a lot of scientists
won't touch it yeah so what do you think
Zak I mean my view basically is to the
extent that people have spiritual
experiences in that they help them I
think that that's absolutely great if
you're asking me can drugs actually
allow people to either see the future
communicate with the dead or be psychics
my answer is until I see evidence
confirming that I don't buy it all right
I have to agree with you on that and I
don't believe in psychics just or like
the spiritual realm per se like that
either uh I tend to actually go around
almost the exact same amount that you
take in this topic I definitely agree
that's like drugs and just I mean maybe
not just psychedelic drugs in general or
any kind of drug can like change your
view and because it gives you a
different perspective on things that you
otherwise wouldn't have yeah I mean
you're talking about something that is
that is affecting your brain and it
would correlate with that that you're
going to have different mental
experiences last thing on this and we've
got a run is I am open to the idea that
what is currently described as psychic
powers can exist I've just not seen
evidence of it yet and I think
ultimately science will explain it I
don't believe it will be supernatural
if it indeed does exist I think we'll
figure out exactly what it is okay Zach
from Illinois thank you so much for the
call Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing